con gritos de putin asesino y fuera de
ucrania es lo que se está celebrando
esta misma tarde en estambul delante del
consulado ruso son una manifestación de
ucranianos y grupos turcos para pedir
que turquía para que rusia se marche de
ucrania que ha sido invadida esta misma
mañana según ha anunciado el presidente
ruso vladimir putin sin embargo turquía
está en una posición entre medias entre
estos dos países por tener muy buenas
relaciones tanto con kiev con moscú de
hecho esta misma mañana ucrania ha
pedido formalmente a turquía que limite
y prohíba los pasos de los barcos de
guerra rusos en los estrechos de los
dardanelos y el boss para los estrechos
que conectan el mar mediterráneo y el
mar negro donde se encuentra la mayor
parte de la flota naval rusa no se
espera sin embargo que que erdogán que
ha hablado después de esta petición
acepte esta petición precisamente porque
turquía está aunque favorable a la
oposición ucraniana está en entre medias
entre ambos países y no puede permitirse
tener una enemistad con rusa que podría
limitar la económicamente muy
severamente y además
a recalentar un conflicto de siria que
podría afectar muy gravemente a turquía
por una nueva ola de migrantes que
podría llegar a territorio turco en
cualquier momento si este terry a este
conflicto sirio se recalentarse como se
haciendo ahora mismo el conflicto
craneano